you know
despite
the two biggest games of the season so
far there's still plenty of other things
happening in the nfl coaches are being
hired and how about this
nick ciriani if you can't get frank
reich to come back and work with carson
wentz frank wright the head coach of the
indianapolis colts next best thing hire
his right-hand man offensively and nick
ciriani siriani expected to be the new
coach of the eagles what was your
reaction when you heard the news that
it's going to be siriani
well for a couple of days this week i
really thought that uh
that the answer was going to be josh
mcdaniels
and
you know mcdaniels had a separate uh
distinct individual
conversation a very long one with
jeffrey lurie
uh i think it was wednesday morning
and i thought mcdaniels was going to get
the job but clearly
you know this job was all about which
coach
the philadelphia eagles thought could
not only pilot their team but could fix
as importantly carson wentz they're all
in on wentz
and mike you know what it it just
creates an interesting situation
where
the philadelphia eagles now
believe that
the
the frank wright disciple
and not the andy reid disciple one of
them either eric b enemy or mike kafka
was going to be the guy to fix wentz
that is what this job is all about
yeah look i agree with that completely
that's what the eagles need to do more
than anything else you mentioned the
josh mcdaniels conversation with jeffrey
lurie i had heard earlier in the week
that
howie roseman wanted mcdaniels and that
the more difficult sales job would be
lurie what you're hearing if we can
harmonize the two together and speculate
a little bit it sounds like mcdaniels
didn't sell laurie or laurie didn't
ultimately sell mcdaniels you know for
josh mcdaniels he's got one more shot
whenever he takes it the question is how
open is the window peter i feel like
that what happened three years ago with
the cult still gets held against him in
some circles i don't know that another
team is concerned that if he says he's
going to take the job at some point
between the verbal commitment and
putting pen to paper bill belichick's
going to get him to change his mind
again but i just feel like there's
something that's been hovering over josh
mcdaniels for the last three years
that's been hard for him to
to eradicate as he
tries to explore these opportunities
possibly be a head coach again
my people clearly are holding
against him the fact that he walked away
from a
uh from a verbal agreement to coach the
indianapolis colts and look i i i know
this situation very well
and the colts are very happy to have uh
to have frank wright as their coach but
how ironic is this think of think of the
irony here
that josh mcdaniels you know a couple of
years after that now three years fully
three years after that
in essence if you think about it
went to try to get a head coaching job
and was the closest
since
you know he almost had the indianapolis
job he had it and then gave it up and
the guy who beats him out for this job
is the disciple of the guy who took
the
indianapolis job
when mcdaniels walked away
so
you know there's going to be a lot of
people who are going to look at that and
and just i mean i don't know who's going
to look at it and say oh my god that is
that is the definition of irony
but
i think
those who don't look at the full
case of josh mcdaniels which i have done
i think they're making a big mistake i
think he's an excellent coach
and uh is going to be a good coach for
somebody
uh in his second time around now he's
just got to get that shot will he get it
i don't know but it's clear that what
happened in indianapolis has dogged him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports